[Music]
[Applause]
foreign
selena kyle catwoman has been in prison
for the last 10 years and she's just
been let out it was after an event
called fools night which took the lives
of the joker the batman and gordon and
selena gets out and comes back to a
gotham city she barely recognizes
because it's been locked down the city
has focused on crime and safety and
also probably given up some privacy and
civil liberties as well so she has to
come back and figure out her place in
this new gotham city and this is a
smaller story about character uh and
it's about the people who you know who
aren't necessarily the big names the
stars you know and seeing how
as they get older
how do they adapt to the times how do
they adapt this new city specifically
you know the lens of selena getting
older you know the world is not kind and
certainly does not treat women fairly
and and that's probably even more
evident as they get older
there's always a saying that gotham is
like this other character you know in
the batman books and part of what i
wanted to explore is how you know we
take these things and look at them from
a more adult perspective so gotham here
is
very much an american city with all the
problems that our cities have
so i wanted to take a look at that and
see how it impacts you know the
the people who got them and then also
the
you know the heroes and villains
[Music]
uncomfortably uh you know the city is
different you know after suffering so
much on fool's night the city has
changed and they've
opted for safety over everything else so
there are no more costumes there's no
more superheroes or super villains but
there are lots of police on the streets
armed police
and
selena has to come back and and see
where she fits in as a career criminal
what can she do now
and and what is her life like and also
just kind of building back after losing
someone you know she thought maybe she
was going to spend the rest of her life
with so
it's
it's very
it's a tough situation for her to be in
and you know having spent the last 10
years in prison i think her life was
very much
on hold and then now she's actually
having to deal with all the
repercussions
i've spent most of my career working
with dc and and it's such a comfortable
place for me i know everybody i love the
characters and and to be given the
amount of creative freedom that we have
with black label is just it's
unbelievable you know i was talking with
my friend jock and we were just amazed
at how much
we're able to do and how lucky we are
i love it um you know i used to work at
dc as a as an assistant editor and i
felt like i got a good idea of what
everybody's job was but getting a chance
to do all of it really gives me a really
fine control over the storytelling uh
you know just little nuances uh you know
even just moving a balloon here or there
or being able to adjust the color
palettes in the scene i love it although
you know there's some times when i feel
like like one of those ridiculous
one-man bands with like a drum on my
back and like a harmonica and you know
and a guitar
but it's great
in the first issue for sure
we we have an appearance by killer croc
and and he certainly becomes like one of
my favorites to write there's just kind
of a lovable goofiness about him there's
a tragedy you know about him as well as
he's gotten older and doesn't have you
know anybody to work for not quite smart
enough to be the boss you just want
better for him and but at the same time
he's such a lovable goof and kind of a
dummy so it's uh he's great to write and
and i hope the readers love him as much
as i do
[Music]
you